I want to jump to this story here we got
a tweet from Gwen Hogan outside ps17 in
Williamsburg kids chant quote we support
Asylum Seekers but not on school grounds
you've got to hear it to believe it
you hear that they're kind of just like
trailing off like muttering let me just
say this is there's a few ways I see
this and this is these kids won probably
we're told to Chances have no idea
what's going on two it's like basically
them chanting thank you government for
hitting me twice instead of Thrice like
the government is forcing illegal
immigrants into your into your schools
and you're like that part's okay just
not in my school please do it to
somebody else not me also uh this this
is so embarrassing this is why
conservatives lose right they're buying
into the framing that you're buying into
their framing by by apologizing in your
statement was like we're like look we're
not against Asylum Seekers okay this is
New York I I understand that
they're having like into the government
can I have another I know but they're
arguably debating from like a
conservative position this is something
people would call right wing like oh
yeah you don't want them uh on school
grounds how bigoted of you it's like
well they're coming out and saying
they're against that but they still feel
this need to apologize thank you I think
you guys want to mixed up Sheamus these
are Urban liberals who are standing
outside cheering for for quote unquote
Asylum Seekers and then being like but
like why in my school yeah maybe it's
just talk you should do it to someone
else I guess maybe more like the
Martha's Vineyard thing yeah I feel like
for me it's like
don't we get mad at the left when they
make young children who confuse about
their gender identity testify before
their state legislature saying like if
you don't allow this medical
intervention to be passed then I will
personally suffer like don't we not like
it when we use children for our talking
points why are we bringing small
children out here to say please don't
send adult I assume they're adult Asylum
Seekers to our school like why are they
having to have this battle why is no
adult fighting for them also I mean just
the fact that you would have to preface
this with I'm not bad I don't have the
bad opinion but I don't want them here
well you're gonna lose because you're
already starting from a position of
sorry
sorry I'm sorry
yeah that does it it's like thank you
government they have another yeah yeah I
saw I'm sorry so this is what happens I
think this story is actually a really
great example of modern politics in that
these Urban liberals say it's okay that
the government does bad things just
please do it to other people yeah so the
government says we want to do a bunch of
bad stuff they say okay so long as it
goes over there yeah I think you're
right instead of just saying no don't do
the bad thing to anybody well it's like
um it's like what we saw with Martha's
Vineyard that was hysterical
they were freaking out like we can't
handle all of these people really it was
like four dozen exactly how did you do
this to us if any community in the
country could handle it it was Martha's
Vineyard they're like round them up get
rid of them but you know there's like no
organic support for the issue when they
roll out the children I remember they
would always do the school walkouts at
first that started with the gun violence
and they had I remember at my high
school
um I forgot what shooting it was but
they had a what they staged a walk out
out of class except the administration
like sanctioned it and literally gave
them a special space to hold it it's
like who were you walking out on the
school I worked for put it on the
official schedule exactly and then they
did this thing with the climate change
walk out and to be frank I think that's
why they're pushing
um a bunch of this transgender you know
gay stuff on kids because I think they
realize the way that they sort of
mainstreamed a lot of these climate
change and school shooting issues was by
getting the kids behind it and having
them do these walkouts and mass protests
they're like if we can get the young
kids you know drinking the Kool-Aid on
this issue right exactly
like what a bizarre size it's like South
Park when they're like What's Going On
We're protesting the War okay yay no
school yeah this looks like the teacher
said kids were at 11 we're all gonna go
protest and kids are like okay I guess
and the funny thing is the kids don't
even have any
enthusiasms
they like they really don't care to say
words and some of the kids are laughing
clearly not paying attention but I'm
just like I don't know I'm not in school
what a crazy proposal I don't know that
specifics but to even have like Asylum
Seekers on school grounds like the fact
that that's something that we're even
debating that there needs to be a
protest about I mean like that but but
there aren't any Asylum Seekers anywhere
because none of these people are Asylum
Seekers they're adult adult male
economic migrants yeah they're not
Asylum I I doubt a single one of them is
an asylum Seeker they are men who are
told online that they can come to the
United States because the borders are
open and there are jobs they go to the
border and then they ask and they talk
to reporters and reporters like why are
you here and they're like because
there's jobs
no I think that is what happens sorry I
can't fix this UFO uh I I think again I
have to go back to we don't like it when
the left trots out children to argue
their talking points so even if you're
trying to say like this is a slightly
um you know an immigration
restrictionist talking point why are we
making the children do it we have to
hold ourselves the same standards that
we hold other people to and I think
you're right I don't think these kids
these kids were like hey we can go
outside we're gonna look film us for
social media haha hilarious like they
don't care and I appreciate that about
them right like their children they just
want to go to school and hang out with
their friends that's why we don't drag
them probably didn't incite this protest
we can't be sure but yeah no it's just
some some uh social studies teacher
who's like I'm gonna tell you about
civil Civic Disobedience I made these
signs for you to hold I had a teacher
once who needed to get exercise so she
would just turn it into a school thing
which is like we have to go outside for
Science and then she would just like
walk around and grow sweating
we're not doing anything for science
it's like we're in a city walking around
the block at least you got to go outside
though that was nice yeah we didn't care
we were like Yay outside and then the
teacher was like trust me it's for
science oh great okay girl we believe
you like I think that's part of it right
our education system is uh not extremely
effective especially these look like
there are a ton of uh young boys young
boys don't benefit well they don't
benefit by sitting at a desk all day
that's not uh the optimal learning
situation for like what are these Middle
School boys I think that we can all
agree it's good to have students get
learning about the news and be engaged
in cultural events but like I think this
is some teacher saying come on let's
organize something I I think it's I
don't know I get frustrated with stuff
like this because it will see this video
and nothing will happen right if there
are really adult men that are being
inserted into the school the fact that
these kids are theoretically upset about
it won't mean anything to the school
board that's kind of hilarious they were
like we got a bunch of adult men who
need to sleep in your school kids
it's like well all right and and here
let me show you this other follow-up
videos this really exemplifies
everything very well listen to this
they're not families who fled war is
what she's saying
fleeing
woman should right away there should be
like
there should be a group of people who go
there and say ma'am I'm sorry but you
can't vote anymore just we're just not a
lot we just so this is all right so this
is one massive problem with the
discourse whenever anyone tries to set
any standard no matter how reasonable
they're met with a million different
concerns about the level of culpability
there might be for people who want to
violate that standard so what she's
essentially saying is well why did they
flee why are they here okay it doesn't
matter they shouldn't be at that school
that's it that's it that's it either
explain to me why that's an appropriate
place for them to be and change my mind
or stop engaging with this conversation
don't give me a million and one reasons
why we should feel bad for them we can
feel bad for a lot of people that we
need to have rules as a society for this
woman you don't approach her and argue
with her and let her ask why you're
blocking say why do you want adult men
in the school just Just give me a reason
and then when she goes their family's
fleeing War and be like okay well that
that's not what we're talking about I I
would I'll play this I'll say okay ma'am
if you came to me with a family and said
this this family fleeing War needs a
place I'd be agree with you but my
question too is why do you want adult
men
by themselves looking for jobs sleeping
in my kids school and also you since
you're so enlightened and empathetic and
understanding why don't you go buy some
hotel rooms for him why don't you take
care of it instead of putting it on the
children of the community by placing
them in their schools I propose I said I
said you know let's get the Republicans
on this one a bill that says all
you know all these Asylum Seekers you
know if someone comes into this country
and applies for Asylum they should be
placed inside the home of uh an urban
liberal Democrat voter go to New York
and say they applied for Asylum so they
get to live in your house sorry sounds
good you voted for it because you know
what happened these people would vote
for border security in two seconds if we
if we did that the issue is this video
exemplifies how people in Democrat
cities vote to bring in illegal
immigrants and then try and force them
on poor people say not in my backyard in
your backyard no no no we're going to
put them in your backyard from now on
let's get that bill these people go to
cities and they put them in your house
this lady who's like their family's
fleeing War let's get two of these adult
men and put them in our home and it's
not just force them it's then guilt and
shame them if you dare to reject the you
know hypothesis that just dozens of you
know fighting age men should just be
able to basically invade your country
invade your house and I think
immigration is one of the issues that
the elites really really love to lie to
us the most about and I know there are a
lot of issues that could compete for
that spot but I think they just love the
issue of immigration in part because I
think at their core they hate this
country they don't think it actually
there's nothing to actually being
American to that them but the fact that
they have the gall to stand up there
whether it's Democrats holding press
conferences you know on the hill saying
that immigration is actually a boon to
America it's actually great for American
workers they're doing the jobs that
Americans want it's such a lie it's so
ridiculous when they're it's depressing
the wages of American workers
particularly people that Democrats
purport to protect the most the minority
communities I just think they they
really get off on lying to the American
people about immigration and it's one of
the issues honestly that red pilled me I
was born and raised in Los Angeles and I
saw firsthand how hypocritical these
people were when it came to not just
immigration but to every issue it was
fine if it was happening elsewhere you
know somewhere where they weren't
impacted but the second it encroached
um not even necessarily in their
backyard but just a little too close for
comfort uh suddenly they they reversed
at least in private on the issue and
they would do everything they could to
make sure it didn't affect them thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time